e
it being little past was it 10:01
now we open the finance thank you
division to work session and I'll call
on Mr landrian to start us off
good morning
everybody so I think today we could
probably fill two hours with kind of
just resetting recalibrating and setting
a plan for the next you know seven work
days essentially until this committee
should have all of its decisions done um
I provided some documents on everybody's
table just very briefly what they all
are one is the um it starts off with the
house finance division 2 recommended
changes to House Bill one and two this
is like our tracking sheets and I'll
walk us through this um it'll look
familiar to those who have been in the
committee before uh the next document is
the house finance division 2 agency
House Bill two draft uh requests um I'll
walk us through that as well then I also
gave you um which I think I had promised
before but hadn't given you till now the
an index to House Bill two as well as
the official sections the back of the
budget sections for House Bill one um
not really a whole lot of heavy lift
there but we'll get to that when we go
through the tracking sheet and then just
so you have it I think I emailed it to
everyone the two amendments that this
committee adopted on bills so on Monday
we have an exec session across the hall
um those are the only two amendments
that this committee um voted for when
did you mail those uh I think back at
the time that I had them drafted okay
yeah yeah those are the two yeah yeah so
thank you um just as we're getting into
this and we we're starting to look at
lines in the budget um I wonder if we
could get an idea of what the division 2
allocation is for money and what are
what they're going to say we have to cut
do we know other divisions seem to know
what theirs is do we know ours well yeah
sort
of so this is still the subject of
discussion um when that allocation
you've heard of
about well that you've heard other You'
apparently heard something other
divisions have um that was
done uh at a time and by someone who
thought differently didn't understand
that adequacy the the funding of local
schools was pretty much not going to be
caught or we probably wouldn't be in
charge
anymore which would disappoint a lot of
people on our side wouldn't wouldn't bum
you out too much
up fair enough in any case I will give
you the number um but that was was under
that you know assumption so there's I
I'm still working to okay redirect
people but they're talking about cutting
about $200 million out of division 2 now
having said that um one of the things
that is in the governor's budget you I'm
sure you're all aware of is the lottery
um piece where which we have not yet um
addressed and there is a plan to uh try
to address that um so we're I'm meeting
with ways of means and with other folks
um to so theoretically half of that
roughly hopefully would be that 200
million I'm talking about so without the
lottery we'd be host in terms of that
cut trying to reduce $200 million um
with that hopefully we'll be in a better
position although still not in a great
position does that answer your question
as I can yeah yeah it helps I'll take
any information um but if what if
Lottery doesn't pass the house doesn't
isn't there still a bill to go to the
house and if Lottery does not pass the
house um are you going to be suggesting
that we just put it into the budget
regardless of what the House vote
is well it it won't be regardless of
what the House vote is because it
doesn't look like they're going to be a
house vote so but the answer to your
question is yes we're just going to put
it in the budget I'll let Mr landing and
speak to the to the the doing that but
that's my understanding that we are able
to do that and and that's the approach
that I'm
envisioning so relative to video Lottery
terminals um the governor did put put
forth a proposal and that's in House
Bill too so making changes to that in
this committee is Germaine inappropriate
we did talk about uh deferring to the
work that house Ways and Means would do
on House Bill
728 um there's no requirement this
committee adopt that we had discussed
that maybe was an approach um so for
instance if house ways a means were to
retain that bill for instance really all
of that work would would fall here if
you did want to pass some legislation
that included VTS and account for the
revenue so I believe they have an exec
session scheduled on that bill Tuesday
and I know there are others also working
on some different uh proposals relative
to this so probably next week we'd have
to get an amendment drafted and review
it and discuss it and then perhaps have
Lottery come in to see if they would um
help us with a revenue estimate or or
Associated hold on um does that no
okay
papovich thank you Mr chair um good
morning I just wanted to make sure I
understand so when when we change fees
and whatnot those Revenue estimates do
they still have to go through way and me
or do we just B them into our part of
the budget I just cannot remember from
last term what was the process for that
so anything that goes through this
committee you can ask Ways and Means for
their input But ultimately the estimates
are part of your plan and when we get
into formulating the Surplus statement
we would rely on the committee to decide
how much revenue you're estimating
associated with that change thank you I
was just worried about the time the
short time frame and I just wanted to
make sure I understand how many Hoops we
got to go through this help we should be
able handle that Allin committee with
maybe some offline discussion if you
wish with either the chair of house Ways
and Means or members from ways of means
to get their input But ultimately that
decision would lie in this committee as
far as how much to estimate on a revenue
provision but okay so guess we'll
continue so I don't I want like to keep
us somewhat focused today but I think
one important thing that we get to we
don't have to get to it right away is
putting a plan together for the next
week uh week plus specifically uh as you
all we we reserved almost every day next
week with some division two time but I
think having some uh focus on what you
want to do on each of those days will be
helpful so maybe when we go through all
this today at the end maybe we can
decide who we want to have in for how
long and on which days and to talk about
what um I suppose I could just Dive
Right into these documents and also as I
go through these are meant to be
somewhat complete I've tried to compile
everything that is kind of in our
division 2 Universe to consider if
there's anything on here that you think
is wrong or you think something's
missing just we'll talk through it when
I update these sheets which I plan to do
every day you meet um I'll I'll add
those in for Monday is fishing game
coming today not today no so nobody's
coming in today but I was suggesting uh
so I sent you all uh pretty hefty amount
of follow-up information they provided
yesterday uh I suggest maybe Monday
morning we have only two hours in
division because of the full Committee
in the afternoon maybe Monday morning we
have fishing game come in and walk us
through those documents we could
probably fill most of the two hours just
going through all that stuff and so we
have Revenue estimates from or not
reeven estimates um fee thing
information from safety are they come in
to present those or what we can have saf
and this is again when we go through all
this today maybe on the back end we can
decide uh what you want to do we can
certainly invite everyone or anybody
back in not necessarily everyone you may
we don't necessarily have to you don't
have to no but if you would like
additional information or to talk
through anything with the agencies we
can invite them back and I'm sure they'd
be more than willing um specific with
safety they did provide some fee um
information some like a some a
spreadsheet to calculate some fee
increases going back and forth with them
on that just to check it for accuracy
right now so I had a few questions in so
I just want to make sure we have a clean
tool to use if you did want to explore
adjusting any fees so I'm still going
back and forth with them on that so just
along those lines you understand what
I've been hoping to do we got back to
the whole money thing I'm hoping we can
use as I think I mentioned this before
but fees in fishing game would they
mention that they were good with some of
the ones in the dedicated funds to make
fishing game fund um
solvent and uh unnecessary to have
General draw General funds similarly
with safe to make the highway fund
solvent and um perhaps even so we we
currently as you're probably aware we
currently provide I think it's $2
million a year to Judiciary related to
their court cases with regard to Motor
Vehicles so one possibility is because
division one of course has issues as
well um is to increase that that amount
which has not been increased for quite
some number of years if we're able to
make the highway fund um well enough off
so I'd say the first document we can
dive into is the the tracking sheet
document so the first one should be on
the top of your piles the house finance
recommended changes to House Bill one
and
two so again this is a should be a
familiar sheet for those who are here
before and what this first page does is
lays out all of the house bill one back
of the budget sections and all of the
house bill two sections that are
assigned to division 2 so on all of the
I will ask that the committee does vote
either you'll make a vote to adopt an
amendment to delete it an amendment to
change it or you just want to accept it
as is how it came to you from the
governor so at some point we'll take a
vote on all of those um and then down
below as we start getting some drafted
uh any more any additional House Bill
two amendments I'll list at the bottom
and then keep track of those um and then
if you look on the next four pages
there are four amendments that the
committee could consider today I I would
look at these as somewhat technical in
nature um and you can see on the first
page here I've bold and highlighted
which section those amendments would uh
change so I don't know if if that's
something you wanted to do today I think
it's a nice easy start to get to do a
couple votes and check a couple things
off but I'll defer to to you all I would
certain love to do that as long as
there's agreement um
on both sides I I think these are fairly
noncontroversial is that I yeah I
believe so too um if you want me to walk
you through them I can real quick so the
first one so on page 46 of House Bill 2
Section 81 the ccsnh Dual and concurrent
enrollment so this was in the governor's
budget um it was also part of uh a bill
that was filed by the house house bill
192 which has been passed and is onto
the Senate so this could be a se you
just delete from House Bill 2 it has
independent legislation going through it
does not tie it House Bill one in any
way I think this a way you could clean
up House Bill too it's no longer
necessary in here and I did speak with I
want to use her last name to be
appropriate here miss Reed um Shan I
know it's Shannon but I was trying to be
a little less a little more formal
Shannon Reed um about this and she is
fine with what went went through the
Senate going on through it's just the
so do you want to go and just deal with
these as we go or how do you want to
handle it you certainly could so in the
past typically what you would do is you
know move it just like an an amendment
to any other Bill move and get a second
and take a vote on it and then I would
know that that amendment's been adopted
and then I'll put that in as part of our
overall package of recommendations okay
motion sir representa Murray second to
delete
well finish complete I deleting it what
oh deleting section 81 yes correct yes
yes um so we're making a motion to
delete section 81 of hb2 on page 46
which is the ccsnh Dual and Curr
concurrent enrollment program credits
per course which actually defines a
limit some limitations on the number of
credits that attendees can get um
without their own expense being being uh
required this is because it's included
in another bill that's passed and this
is right so this language was in a bill
that we've already passed the house and
it's actually already on its way to the
Senate and the the um representative
from ccsnh was comfortable with that
this
approach this is patience sure yeah take
take your
time what is the bill number again is
there a bill number it's an HB
H so HB hb2 is the bill and it's section
81 m Mr chair yes ma' in the past two
and and if everyone agrees sorry to cut
everybody off a way to perhaps simplify
this because we will have a lot of votes
is just a show of hands oh instead of a
roll call on on every single yeah you
may get to situations where you maybe
want to do a roll call on certain
amendments later on but most of this you
I think if everyone agrees a show our
hands just to I think it may help the
our clerk as well as just overall
favor unanimous unless you're going to
vote against
it do we need do we need to report a
second for that or Pap second did it he
second
peace you miss a day or two nobody
and and what I'll do also again just
remind everyone on by Sunday night to
get ready for Monday you'll get a brand
new one of these with you know the
committee's actions populated in this
far right column so you'll be able to
see you know and again if anyone's like
hey we didn't agree on that or I'm you
know just bring it up to me and I make
mistakes and you know if if if
something's wrong in there we want to
make sure we get it
right what was
yeah so moving on similarly section
sections 143 and 144 of House Bill 2 are
relative to extra Duty functions of the
police standards and training uh
Specialists this also was included in
House Bill 2 but it also had a separate
bill that bill House Bill 778 has passed
the house and gone over to the Senate as
well so similarly I think you could
delete this it doesn't not need to be an
to and the last one was it was HB 193
on 62
yes this isn't just related to overtime
isn't Al certain
people
certain I think this is relative to like
uh details like to per allow them to to
partake in police details right but it's
a certain it's not just is it so it's
any of the police standards people or
their training Specialists I think the
the language yeah I'm assuming certified
you know not not entire the entirety of
their staff okay for law enforcement
crowd control for public or private
events extra Duty performed outside
them
okay he's good it would be nice if I
motion represent papic I will make such
motion have a
second representative hackin
Phillips let me know when you're ready
this is madam clerk we are accepting
sections we're we're we're deleting
we're deleting those sections because
they are in a separate bill that is
passed to the Senate
HB I'm sorry HB 778
778 yes so I'll just clarify so the
motion is to delete sections 143 and 144
of hb2 on page
62 as the same language or equivalent
language is in HB 778 which has already
Senate so just let us know when you're
ready and we'll take a okay so all in
the next one if we're ready to to move
on I would think would be it's page 64
of House Bill 2 Section 151 and there is
an amendment here
to uh correct it so the way that um this
came to us in House Bill 2 uh if you
have House Bill 2 in front of you you'll
notice on lines 19 of page
64 yeah this is where the intention was
to delete that last sentence but the way
it was drafted it just added that same
language again so if you look on page
four of the tracking sheet package I
sent you you'll see the amendment
strikes out that last sentence that was
the intention all along the Department's
good with this this is what the go
Governor intended to put in um there's
no fiscal impact here I I think this is
a pretty harmless
change it was yeah the way it came to us
so we would want to just adop accept
motion than you move to accept amendment
number
H represented poet Papa seconds
president Melly makes the motion and the
motion is to accept the amendment that
is an correction to section 151 of
hb2 on page
64 basically deleting a sentence that
should have been deleted but was
mistakenly not
deleted and let me know when you're all
set okay um all in favor just raise your
hands any
opposed that's unanimous
thank
[Laughter]
that all right Mr land and the the last
of the Amendments that we have drafted
for today would be on page 72 of house
bill to section
178 and we would delete this section and
the reason is and this is why I gave you
house bill one sections the back of the
budget sections this is the same
language that is also oo in the back of
house bill one it's section two of House
Bill one Sor sorry section four of house
bill one this language for the uh
Authority for the Lottery Commission to
acquire tickets and do this is
boilerplate language that has been in
the back of house bill one for many many
years before my time um this allows them
to buy their ticket inventory their
ticket stock um it's
boilerplate why it was included in House
Bill 2 I think was a mistake because it
is it was included in the governor's
House Bill one document so I think if
you delete it from House Bill two we can
just decide if you just want to give it
a thumbs up when we get to House Bill
one and I'll get us to that point but it
definitely doesn't need to be in both it
should be in the back of house bill one
for
motion representative papovich I'll move
Murray so this is a motion to
adopt Amendment 2025 d89
toh which deletes section 178 from hb2
on page 72 as the language is this the
are you ready M Clark all in favor raise
your hands that's everybody anybody
opposed
no it's it's
no
[Laughter]
to so yeah yeah no you're welcome uh so
those are the four amendments that we
had today I think pretty easy pretty uh
you know just mostly technical in nature
if the committee wants we can roll right
to the top of this tracking sheet and if
there's any sections that you heard from
the Departments it's something that's
inous built to you don't think you are
going to want to change you'll accept it
the way the governor and the agencies
Put It Forward you could just you could
vote today to accept those uh two right
off the bat I would say or the part of
the house bill one SE that I gave you
the education general fund and
appropriation limits for um university
and Community College system and the
Lottery Commission which we just talked
about those are boilerplate back of the
budget things that have existed uh
there's no impact with those you can
take a look or you know just think about
it for next time we meet um that's where
are you right now on House Bill one so
those sections that I gave you the back
of the budget sections of house bill one
because remember we do have two separate
bills we have to deal with here it look
it's um I don't have a hard copy but
it's the it was yes no not House Bill
one
yeah
21165 yeah it's it's the actual cover
page of house bill one and then just the
back of the budget
sections the big portion of house bill
one is your big budget book that's not
printed in that this is just a small
document of just the back of the budget
sections so sections two and four are
assigned to
two to decide on and both are
boilerplate consistent sections of house
B one that have existed for years
um so it' be section two of that bill
that you have in your hand I think it's
on page 7even it says
723 yeah yeah so on line 28 you'll see
the
so so what did you oh back to the budget
section okay here we go well I mean we
could hold off on these this is fine no
no no let's keep moving so you said line
28 page 723 L yeah got
it section two and four yeah I I I
actually am going to suggest perhaps
holding on two section two until you
decide what you're going to do with the
university and Community College systems
budget we probably won't change it but
just in case I think it's good to just
have that okay section four the Lottery
Commission I think you could just give
that a thumbs up if nobody had any any
issues with that one L 11 line 11 on
yeah page 724 is what the header says
it was
deleted it appeared in both bills out of
the governor's office so we just deleted
it from House Bill two it always resides
in house bill
one yeah yes so just as a reminder to
everyone um we have time to review the D
thing so don't feel the pressure when
you look at a paragraph take a few
seconds to read it because it's much
easier to express a concern before we
the vote on it then to then reconsider a
vote and start anchoring with stuff with
approved so take a few seconds we have
the time we're getting it done so
everything here is new in hb1 we need to
approve all these sections as well
essentially is that
accurate uh is this just hb1 so this is
just House Bill one the back of the
budget sections House Bill one that
everyone always refers to like the
budget lines that's section one of host
Bill 2 these are the sections two and
after that we're talking about so we're
not talking about funding levels here
we're talking about a couple like
footnotes essentially of the and we need
to approve each one of them just the
ones that are assigned so basically just
section two and four and then if we do
abolish any positions with your
decision- making we would update the
section relative to abolish positions as
well but really sections two and four
two so are are we all good with this no
no
okay I oh read read it read
it and we we are going to have voting a
lot next week if no one is feeling
prepared to do stuff today and you know
we want to have there's no rush we we we
feel like we've already made pretty good
progress with those four amendments
today so I'm I'm pleased so this is a
smaller section for H it we've certainly
had bigger we've certainly had more
sections in this yeah would you rather
would you rather read over the weekend
we don't have V on today I don't know I
mean everybody else is ready it's just
the new okay okay no no take take it
take your time I'm going to take a break
look
it's again on the mic so people who may
be watching know what's going on we were
reviewing the fact that this is a work
session therefore it's perfectly okay
for somebody to take a minute to read
something and see if they're ready to
vote on it or not so we are taking that
time we'll uh start uh working again as
Mickey for Mr Lan for clarification the
action that we are looking to take on
section for if nobody objects is to just
approve it as written in the back of hb1
because it had already been the
duplicate language has been just removed
from hb2 so now the correct language is
only one place to make housekeeping
cool means you're not already at we
don't have a motion do we not yet you
were out okay well not why you took over
um do I have a motion I would leave how
issues how about
Harry there you go
Harry no I'll make a motion to approve
uh section four of page oh sorry I'll
make a motion to approve section 4 of
page 724 in hb1 as
Murray I guess I should add referring to
discussion ready Madam clerk all in
favor raise your
so so we will be deferring action then
per the advice of Mr landrian for
section two on page 723 regarding the
education budget abundance of caution
and all that thank you and and just a
reminder to everybody to all of these
are just recommendations as we go along
everything can be Revisited and has been
in the past and nothing's final final
until we kind of hit hit the end of our
deadline so I I think we can probably be
done with this first page of this
tracking sheet today tracking package um
but as we continue on the coming days
um every one of these amendments or
excuse me every one of these sections in
House Bill two we usually ask that you
vote on one way or another just so we
know what the committee's intent and
intent is whether it's going to stay in
or come out or or whatever um and and
this will apply to everything as we
continue on we are getting near the the
end of our um close deadline so if
anyone has an amendment Now is really
the time to reach out to me and I'll
help you draft it and include it in this
package similar to the ones that you saw
in here today the technical ones um you
know we we're getting to the point where
you're going to have to start closing
out some things you know as the days
move
on thank you since Mr landan is bringing
it up there was something that I think I
haven't managed to share with a
committee yet which is one of the items
we were discussing in um the revenue
committee for the fish and game um one
of the concerns of that committee was
that right now when you take a hunter or
a you know um Trapper class you don't
have to pay for the class you take it
for free you could take the class and
never even apply for the exam and the
concern of the committee was that that
seems to be a bit wasteful because we're
basically giving free training to people
who may just be wasting our time and
taking our slots combining that with the
fact that the department has a tendency
to fill its classes and not really be
able to offer new classes leading to
some people never being able to attend
one of the thoughts of that committee
which I'd like to share with this
committee to see if it makes sense for
everybody was to require people to pay
for the license first and then be
allowed a free training class now there
is a test that needs to be taken and if
they fail the suggestion of the previous
committee was to allow them to take the
class pass a second time to ensure they
pass but the idea was that asking for
this would increase the number of people
that take the training class that
actually get the license because it
would basically say Hey you have to
commit to applying for the license
before it will let you take the free
training class and again it's something
that I didn't bring up yet so I want to
bring it up now if the committee feels
it's a good idea to at least have an
amendment drafted along those lines we
could ask Mr L to draft it and then
review it and uh you know decide whether
it makes sense but I didn't want to just
ask him to draft an amendment without
the committee opining folks I think I'd
wait if fishing game is coming in on
Monday wait and them talk about that the
other thing which is a little more
compelling to me is um it has to be very
frustrating with all the dedicated funds
that can't be used for anything else and
so they don't raise the rates because
they're only going to have money sitting
there to have that a cap on it so that
Surplus can go to their operating and
allow them to have the opportunity so um
I feel a little more if we're going to
go in a direction if we only how we can
go in a 100 directions hopefully we
won't um but I'm pretty much behind that
as far as I understand it now but with
fishing game coming in Monday I would be
happy for that but I think that's an
amendment we should consider for fishing
game would it be productive given that
this was discussed with them in the fall
and they did not really seem to be
opposed to it per se would it be more
productive to maybe have an amendment Ed
on Monday so they can opine on the
language and then we can consider this
I'm not looking to have the amendment
adopted without talking to them and
giving them an opportunity but maybe if
we have the an initial draft of of the
amendment it make the Monday discussion
more
productive uh I'm not sure we can get
all that I mean we would have to see if
we can get an amendment turned around
for Monday morning which may be tricky
but um I can I can work with you and and
start getting something drafted we can I
I would be happy to if that's the will
of the committee but otherwise I'm I'm
happy to wait if the committee feels we
should wait until Monday morning just
trying to find the most productive way
of getting that done you know we do have
a lot of moving parts
so I don't think it hurt for you to get
here with band again and at least get
you know start the process so who knows
what you're looking for whether it gets
done by Monday morning or not as a
separate issue so I'll start the process
on Amendment which to summarize will
require Fish and Game to charge people
who register for a class say starting
July 1st or whenever the budget gets in
place right it will require it to charge
the people the license they would owe
for the hunting license and trapping or
whatever and um they would have two
opportunities to take the class in in
included in that fee right does that
make sense that's kind of what we were
doing in the fall but would that be
acceptable cuz the concern was if you
charge them the hunter license and they
fail the exam they'll be frustrated so
the second time to take the hunter
license class for the same fee seems
reasonable and I think is trying um I'm
just curious how logistically that would
happen though I mean when you go to get
your hunter license you get your hunter
license
so how would they handle that the same
way they handle it right now when you
need to get your hunter's license you
can pay it whatever outfit you want and
as soon as you put your application in
you can go and schedule your class so
they don't send the hunter license until
after the class well you cannot possibly
qualify for it until you pass the class
there is a written test there is a field
day so they already have a pretty tough
process in terms of you know making sure
you are eligible and you are qualified
this would only move the payment from
after everything is concluded to the
beginning of the process so you don't go
through the training class and then just
never apply it's wasteful I mean we're
spending time and money to train people
who don't
apply okay thank
you I was just going to say with
everything we're going through could we
wait till you know you can I guess start
your process but wait till fishing game
gets here to um get it from the the
deer's mouth maybe
the I'm fine with that I I can wait I
mean I don't want
to
be I just don't know how you're going to
go get the D the hunter's license you'll
have the license what makes you go to
the class you've already got the license
you don't get the license you just pay
the fee and you only get your license at
the end of the you know approval process
the idea is not to get people a free
ride in taking a class without ever
intending to apply for a license which
happens quite a few times you believe
that funny I by the department in uh the
fall seem to indicate that yeah there
are quite a few cases of people that for
whatever reason take the clock and then
their plans change or you know they move
or whatever and they never apply and
we're also again unable to serve other
people who want to get into classes and
the classes are full and the department
needs the revenue it's not only the
revenue from the license itself even
though that's meaningful but it's also
you know some of the Pitman Robertson
money is allocated based on how many
licensed people we have in the state so
it's there are good reasons to continue
to help increase the number of licensed
hunters and Fishers and Trappers and so
on so this is an attempt to make that
work a bit better it shouldn't be a huge
change in Revenue but every little thing
helps we could just charge for the
class but anyway let's wait for a
fishing
game all right Mr so yes so to confirm
we will invite fishing game in for our
10 to 12 block on Monday and like I said
they have a lot of other deliverables
including some of the things you talked
about and that and we can bring that up
too with them so just to follow up on
that is is that the only thing we'll be
able to get done on Monday we limit them
to an hour and S an hour to get some
other things done
um have you taken they did provide quite
a bit of information um have I read it
all no I think you'd have to be very
efficient to get through them in an hour
but it's possible um there's always the
option of recessing when we're done with
them in the morning
until after the the exact and then we
could come back later in the afternoon
if we have stuff we wanted to get done
I'm just concerned I know there's a lot
yeah and we don't have Thursday of
course and we only have Friday morning
which we I yeah because I have a I have
the judicial thing in the afternoon
yeah all right so the next page we'll
jump to is Page Six of the the tracking
sheet packet and the orientation of the
so is everybody
is it's uh we're in the the packet that
the front page looks like this and then
page six of this document yep all right
perfect so this is where
uh this is where I've captured all of
the we'll call it uh like funding
changes that have e either been proposed
by an agency an additional prioritized
need or just other changes discussed
just to try to get everything on here
for you to consider um and I can walk us
through very quickly everything here so
Department of safety's only funding
change request was relative to funding
the northern border Alliance so this was
a 600,00
request they came in and when they met
with us this was uh something they had
brought up uh fishing game is pretty
incomplete in both of these documents
here because they are they just sent a
whole new package yesterday like I said
so the only thing on here for them as of
right now was their general fund support
that they had testified to us when they
came in I expect after Monday I'll
probably add more to this Department of
Transportation lines three four and five
were there additional prioritized needs
relative to Highway programs the
retention incentive program equipment
replacement and winter maintenance uh
line six the transit operating match you
recall we had a work session with
Transit operators uh relative to that uh
Mr landrian on the Department of
Transportation requests as you go
through them could you indicate which of
them must be funded from the general
fund and which of them could be funded
from one of the dedicated funds they
have available I'm trying to understand
because that is a complicated Department
right I don't want to use funds
improperly but I would like to minimize
the use of General funds whenever other
funds May available even if the highway
find for example has a structural
deficit we're going to try to address it
so anything that can be spent for the
Department of Transportation from from
one of their dedicated funds I would
really like to hear whether it's
possible even if that fund right now
does not seem to have the funds
available sure um I mean for for the
first three those are his ially just
unrestricted Highway fund appropriation
I'm not sure what dedicated funds at
Department of
Transportation is is that something you
know again Highway fund y you know
obviously the turnpike fund is
restricted
but if any parts of those expenditures
could come from dedicated funds even if
you don't have the answer right now and
please note you said historically I get
the history but historically and
possible are different things we may
have done things a certain way for a
while if it's possible to do them
differently I'd like to explore it I'm
just trying
to find
funds in ways that would reduce the need
for us to straight out cut or deny
requests I'm looking for ways to grant
them their requests with less of an
impact on the general fund so if that's
at all possible when you say dedicated
funds you're including the highway fund
aren't
you every dedic
anything anything that's not general
fund no specifically when you I I think
there's some confusion here when you say
dedicated you're including the highway
fund I spe I specifically said yeah the
highway fund the turnpike fund any other
okay so uh lines three through five are
Highway fund requests uh line six is the
only general fund request of the
department and that is not something
that Highway fund would be an
appropriate use for
which is why it's a general fund request
um line seven you remember they talked
about their P3 um the operator uh
agreement that they had for with do
Portsmith facilities I believe it was so
they are trying to come up with a way to
restrict the revenue that they collect
for that for that purpose under the
operator agreement
um they have language and you'll see it
um when we get to the house bill two
section
uh something we could add to house bill
to that just restricts the revenue in
the budget doesn't create a dedicated
fund they didn't seem to get a warm
reception to the idea of establishing a
brand new dedicated fund for this so
they did come up with a a workaround
that would at least restrict that money
for its agreed upon use um what you see
here would be revenue from that
agreement $52,000 in fiscal 26 and
$78,000 in fiscal 27 just to put it in
house bill one to reflect that uh new uh
function that they'd be
doing line number eight is nothing you
really have to worry about right now so
if you recall um a portion in a
specifically um is a big one but also
some of the construction lines in the
betterment program as well as the S SP
367 account are driven by your Revenue
estimates so for um a portion in a this
is your Highway block grants to cities
and towns so 12% of the previous years
Highway fund Revenue essentially motor
vehicle fees and road toll gets paid to
cities and towns so the numbers that are
reflected on here and then the
construction lines a portion of the road
toll uh goes to the betterment program
the three cents we've heard from the
Department about that so the amounts
that are represented on here would be
decreases to the governor's budget
because house Ways and Means estimates
were a little bit lower than the
governor
so these accounts are uh tied to Warrant
language that the department would still
just pay whatever it is this is just
accurately reflecting in the budget what
we think those will be based on the
revenue so somewhat technical but at
least it it aligns your spending plan
with your Revenue plan the reason why
I'd say hold off on these for now is
this committee is discussing changing
motor vehicle fees so these would be
changed as a result of that so we'll
we'll hold on to that to see what we do
with with fees can you go over that just
again um I always don't like the
parenthesis
uh so this is money that we don't
basically have to find this is money
that oh sorry I should have said that at
the begin so all of these columns
represent a change to the budget you're
working from yeah so if it's a
parentheses that's a reduction so this a
reduction from what is in the governor's
budget because Ways and Means has so
we're they're assuming lower Revenue so
therefore we'd assume these programs
would have lower
costs so this is a cost savings this
isn't another hole we have to fill I
mean yeah I mean uh you could look at it
that way
yeah but just keep in mind the reason
it's a savings is because the top level
top number the top line revenue num is
going
down the the net the net impact of
adjusting for the revenue change and
adjusting for these is a it hurts your
bottom line compared to the governor
because overall you're You're Expecting
less Revenue so um next set is the
department Department of Education so
lines 9 through 12 um the first three
lines are their additional prioritized
needs they talked about their learning
uh platform software uh State Testing
expanding to do a PSAT for 10th graders
and then the uh position for a state
assessment administrator which is
already an existing position that is
fully federally funded they're asking to
split it half and half general fund and
federal fund because that position does
non-federal work as well so they're
trying to expand the the use of that
position uh line 12 the uh the
department had in their uh presentation
that there was 10 brand new uh positions
in Workforce Innovation division uh
relative to De uh Disability Services
determination they don't exist currently
they were put in their agency budget
request back in August they're saying
those can come out they're not going to
need or fill those so that's what you
see there it's only federal funds not
going to help your general fund requests
in any way uh and then on line 13 of
this document if you remember they they
provided some detail on vacant positions
so the commissioner had said here's some
vacant positions that we really want to
keep and here are some positions that
could be abolished um they they provided
a revised estimate of that or a revised
schedule of that which I sent to you so
the original number I think was 29
positions they backed it down to 20
here can we just go back you as as above
when you talked about um the 10 new
positions um on line 12 being Federal
that really has no bearing on the budget
that would be true also of the education
the um those are all federal positions
on line
13 yes in line 13 the federal positions
I think there were three General funded
positions and then the rest were Federal
so there is a general fun portion there
the GF I'm talking about the federal
ones Federal so those are federal and so
the federal ones don't impact us right
would you take the positions
away basically what just the FED as I
understand the federal government
required the positions and we don't need
the positions so we he doesn't wants to
take take them out of the budget they
don't impact our general fund you're
right but there's no money to take out
since they're Federal it does not affect
us it's just it's more housekeeping
almost yes yeah you would uh align your
budget document House Bill one with I
guess anticipated um programmatic uses I
guess of the department I think the
commissioner had stated he didn't expect
he'd be able to fill those
positions um and if he could if for
instance they have the money and are
able to hire they could come to the
fiscal committee and establish a
temporary position through the bium to
and do that so this would be a uh just
to reflect in your house bill one that
you're not anticipating those positions
Ro just curious how many were um the FED
positions do we know I'd have to double
check I believe it was three general
fund and on line
13 uh three of them were general fund
and the remainder remain yeah we're
Federal thank you repr papovich thank
you and and just to be clear as a former
CPA I agree that the FED funds do not
directly impact our budget but carrying
those positions when we don't need
them just tends to confuse matters when
you budget because now you have a budget
that's bigger than it should be and then
you got to account for the fact that
they are on field so while it doesn't
impact the budget having a clearly a
more readable budget that easier to read
benefits both the department us and
everybody who's trying to understand the
you know department of education budget
so yeah I wish we could save more money
there instead inad of just saying well
Federal money it's in and out but it
does provide much needed Clarity and a
clear direction to the department so I
think it's still good measures to take
even though we don't benefit you know as
much as we'd
like and that and those two lines line
12 and 13 if you're ultimately going to
going to want to do those or a
combination of them or in some variation
I personally would ask that you do it
maybe on the front end of next week
because there is some budget entry data
entry involved with that that I would
have to handle and it would just be
something that I would prefer more time
on I don't know if you would need more
information relative to those if we
could we could always track that down
for you but um that could be something
perhaps you consider early on next
week I personally I would be comfortable
acting now but recognizing that most of
my colleagues may want to review
specific I would suggest specific
information I would suggest we add this
to the Monday morning after fishing game
discussion and you know maybe Mickey if
you Mr landrian if you can have that
detail list of the positions to because
that seems to be where the questions are
coming from which positions are the
exactly how many of each and whatnot so
if we have a nice list pulled from the
list of positions that he has on Monday
this so moving on lines uh 14 through 16
so we heard from the Department of
Education losing track of days um Monday
afternoon and uh as part of the
afternoon session um there was
discussion about the estimates relative
to charter school funding and efas and
EFA phaso grants so the numbers on here
are the difference between the estimates
provided by the department and what the
governor funded those programs at under
current law um we have a couple bills
coming this way House Bill 115 relative
to EFA eligibility and House Bill 563
relative to adequacy
um at some point we'll probably have a
big day of Ed funding type discussions
this is just carried on here to show if
you wanted to fully fund at the
Department's estimates this is how much
it would be above and beyond the
governor's budget but like I said
depending on what you do with those
bills and if you incorporate them into
your budget package these numbers may
change and and we'll track
that line 17 um we did hear that Bedford
approved full day
kindergarten so the numbers carried on
here are uh reflective of the state
paying adequacy on the remaining half of
those students for first year of
implementation would be the 25 26 school
year coming up and then those kids would
be part of full adequacy uh after that
we may get slightly revised numbers I'm
carrying a half a million dollars here
the department going to give me more
true numbers it probably won't move a
ton but that's something that I think we
kind of have to carry under current law
that's what they would get paid so that
to me is somewhat of a surplus statement
adjustment we would just carry
kindergarten aid for Bedford as an
anticipated cost at the department will
will
have U moving on uh Lottery Commission
came in with two requests one for the
security system one for the Ada building
uh compliance improvements those are
sweep Stakes funds
um I'll leave it at that you guys can
decide if you want to uh fund those
not weren't those in their presentation
they were talking about yes that okay
and and that's that's what this document
is is meant to do is compile all of
those requests from all the agencies
that either came in during their
presentations to you or maybe have come
since then and I'm just trying to
compile everything so nothing Falls to
the cracks here just wanted to make sure
yep that is it is the same request they
spoke
to uh police standards and training on
page seven uh I have it broken up as two
separate items here um they did ask to
unfund one of their generally funded
positions and transfer that money into
class 27 to pay for an oit position it's
a net zero change um this was their only
budget
request n Z change I think except that
right now that position where on funding
was vacant anyway so we were expecting
it to lapse so in a sense they are
asking for new money they are just
trying not to create a new appropriation
I'm just trying to make sure I recap the
discussion correctly right so right now
they don't have the it and they don't
have that position filled they would
like to get the it position and they are
eliminating the appropriation need by
trading off as it were of vacant
position but they are getting a new
employee technically we could unfunded
position not approve their it and have a
saving there if we so
decide that's correct thank
you it's it's Net Zero in their budget
proposal
yeah so that concludes the um funding
impact changes I have from the
Departments that they brought through
um again if if a member would like to
you know make a motion on one of those
and support that or some variation of it
or do something else that an agency
never brought up like you want to reduce
a a line by this amount or add amount to
this you can work with me and I can come
up with an amendment I would add it to
this put an amendment you know separate
one so people can see what you're
looking to do um but those I just ask we
start getting those out you know
probably first and next week hopefully
we start start that
discussion all right next moving on is
uh the bills that we've had so the first
subset here is bills that we've already
had work sessions on so House Bill 129
was relative to evidence-based
definition within public education the
department of Ed had asked for a
position in their fiscal note the bill
itself does not have an appropriation or
authorization for a position we retain
that bill so at this point it would stay
retained the bill would stay retained if
this committee want to add that language
to house bill to or or and or uh fund a
position that the department says you
can you can do it any which way you want
you could add it to House Bill 2 and not
provide any funding you could add it to
House Bill 2 and provide the position or
committee similarly house bu
133 um this one was slightly different
in that it did have a general fund
appropriation in the bill uh we also
retained this bill so it's subject to
working with the Department
um but they had also suggested in
addition of the $40,000 for software
that they would need a position to
administer um the changes in the bill
again it's up to the committee to decide
if you want to include this legislation
in your house bill too and then whether
I will Al also point out yesterday I
think it was House Bill 763 relative to
it's like aeds and sports and public
schools that that bill passed and I'm
not sure why but was not referred to
finance there was a small $80,000 a year
general fund appropriation in that bill
so the Surplus statement for the house
finance committee's overall U budget
will carry $80,000 a year to the
Department of Safety for that bill it
didn't come to us for review but that
was $160,000 spend over the
bayum unrelated to this bill but
Department of Safety
related I think it was 763 I had to
double check the number but it was
relative to AED availability in in
sports in schools so if it is an
increase how do we handle that because
you know potentially just you know
hypothetically what if it is something
we wouldn't fund
so the way we handle it is we'll carry
on the Surplus statement of the house
finance committee's overall plan a spend
an appropriation adjustment of $80,000 a
year if this committee doesn't want to
approve that which in the past this has
happened you could put something in
House Bill 2 that says the provisions of
house bill whatever of the 2025 session
shall not take effect so it's clearly as
part of your budget package you don't
want to spend or you don't want to spend
the money that the house as a body
passed so you're kind of undoing the
effectiveness of that if you recall I
think we did that two years ago with a
um a school nutrition related bill yeah
so will you be including a reference to
that on the Surplus statement so we can
actually see that in yeah I mean it's a
small number obviously and uh you may
not see a surplus statement until after
the division's done its work right so
usually we don't compile a surplus
statement in in its final form that
you're used to seeing until all the
division recommendations are done I I
thought you were carrying the the bills
somewhere that have passed we're
carrying them but I'm just saying as far
as a document that's public we we don't
update the the quote Surplus statement
this is this is a general fund
expenditure so I'll update education
trust fund Highway and um fishing game
for you since that's kind of contained
to this committee the general fund
Surplus statement we're not going to
update regularly because all three
divisions are working simultaneously
Mike Kane in our office is he's tracking
all that daily but he's not putting out
a new document necessarily every day so
I guess I just trying to understand how
we might be reminded of it would it
would it appear here or just nowhere um
you don't have to do anything else at
this point unless you want to undo it
well I understand that but sound mean I
I can add it to the list I could add it
to um just as a note on here as a
reminder yeah as but I don't want
to yeah I'll come up with a way to
present that yeah come with a new a new
new chart or whatever new
table there you
go I just want to I just want to make it
clear would it's not a decision division
two made at this point it was
house but at least I'll list it as
something you
can uh the next three bills are well
we'll go one at a time I guess the math
learning communities this is another
bill we're going to retain um this is
part of ccsnh H's budget line which
jumping back up to the previous section
usnh and ccsnh did not have any requests
so that's why they were not included in
the first listing that we went through
we retained that we were I'm sorry sorry
we retain the idea of the funding we're
passing the house bill 494 of the policy
yeah we're passing the statutory changes
of that's the otpa recommendation for
Monday right the informal retain is the
considering what to do with the funding
because the appropriation was taken out
passed I'll go slightly out of order
House Bill 716 dual and concurrent
enrollment same thing uh that bill is
retained so math learning communities
dual and concurrent enrollment will be
considered with wherever you decide to
land with ccsnh H's overall funding and
how you want to earmark dollars for
specific
programs and then lastly House Bill 7
671 the kindergarten literacy Readiness
we heard from folks earlier this week on
that I think it was this week um maybe
it was last week uh so this was the
contract cost presented by the
department Department of Education
$600,000 a year as well as some small
costs for the uh uh HHS had some related
uh cost of the bill
so those items will
essentially unless somebody asks me for
an amendment if we don't draft anything
and put in House Bill two they
through like won't go anywhere so those
those bills are retained right the money
and everything about these bills was
retained so they'll just stay retained
unless you add them to House Bill
2 all the way through we'll see the
begin in
January I had a question about that last
spell Mr chair um Mickey I thought there
was a dollar appropriation for 671 but
when I look on your sheet you've got the
600,000 that they thought it would
actually cost to run the program yeah so
are you just reading between the lines
there I'm I'm telling you the cost yeah
the there was a dollar appropriated for
that one the if you wanted to fully fund
the the agency request that's what's
thank uh next section so 20 lines 26
through 31 these are bills that were uh
referred to us yesterday with the
exception of House Bill 713 that was the
week before um I'll very quickly go
through these EFA Bill we talked about
that uh House Bill 563 calculation of
adequacy Grants we're going to have to
dive into that
bill house bill 675 this was the limit
on School District Appropriations the
local budget cap I guess we'll call it
there's no State impact there so um
that's why there's zero dollars carried
um mile marker on Route 112 House Bill
713 the Department of Transportation um
estimated about three a quarter of a
million dollars of federal funds that
they could use for that but it would
maybe displace other
projects
um catastrophic Aid special head and
then the cell phone
bill on 713 the mile markers on Route
112 I just wanted to get an idea from
the committee if they feel that we need
to debate a lot or that's something that
we can just approve and move on it seems
to be a policy decision that was clearly
made by the house and it's Federal money
I think the department can handle the
prioritization of their Federal money
just fine I'm just trying to see if we
can get something off the table cuz it's
a darn table and it's creaking and uh
you know do we necessarily need to
notice that we're voting on it we do
unfortunately so we'll have to push
maybe till Monday we could do that so
this this is a question now that we've
kind of gone through these we'll have to
schedule a work session on these
remaining bills the work session not yet
completed
so we there's a couple ways we could do
this we could split it up into easier
um uh you know do the easy ones and get
those out and then save some of these
education ones and have a longer work
session dive in deeper on those or do
them all the same day and just vote on
them or how you want to do but at this
point the only day we're talking about
or the earliest we're talking about
would be Friday so we're meeting Monday
Tuesday Wednesday and Friday next week
but you can't but how are you going to
notice them they're in the calendar as
budget work sessions now so we've got it
reserved and I can notice a a calendar
notice or seriously not a calendar note
it's just a posting I I think it's 48
Hours 2 I have to check check with the
clerk but I've already put in a request
to Janet to say if we posted a work
session today what's the earliest we can
schedule it for okay and so maybe it's
Tuesday maybe it's Wednesday but
whatever day that is I'd like to get
these off our table I would um but then
the question is how much time would you
want to a lot for these
discussions like did you want to really
dive into each of the bills during this
work session or do you just want to have
a bang out the work session retain you
know pass what you can quickly like
we've done in the past and then have a
longer day talking about budget
education trust F that sort of thing and
that's where it's up to the committee to
decide well my sense is well when it
comes to the that part of the budget
with Charter Schools and all that kind
of thing is there's probably need a
longer day and some of these are
included in that so those I don't think
would get banged out but the ones that
could get banged out I'd like to do as
early as possible you you could you
could uh I mean you could just have a
little like just open discussion here is
is your intention to and I'm going to go
retain I don't know about 675 where
anyone wants to go with that I'm just
thinking how quickly could you just vote
on these and then just get to that next
step like the like representative
papovich Miller just said SE 713 you
maybe could just pass but then 773 781
those are part of your budget so you
just retain those and discuss those as
part
of
so um I guess we could talk about the
retain part of it but that's not that's
just sort of putting off the I mean at
this point once we discuss them aren't
we to the point of doing something
Beyond saying retain and wait for
another day because we're gonna be out
of days so yes but I'm just thinking if
if the intention we we've just got to
get a requirement done out of the way
have a work session on these bills take
a vote on those bills but I think you
could just dispose of them pretty quick
in that regard but then have a longer
work session to dive all them I to
concur with Mr landrian I think we got
to get the notice out of the way as fast
as we can so everybody has the notice
and we've met that we all know that
we'll probably need more time to figure
everything out but if we could schedule
a work session for all the bills that we
did not complete a work session on that
will take care of the notice issue and
then if we can solve it during that work
session great if not we have a very
short time to continue working on them
but this needs to get out get be you
know get get done and get out of the way
so we don't have further delays yeah
once you make an a vote to retain now we
can discuss those issues as part of our
regular budget work sessions which we've
got scheduled I'm going to schedule them
every day basically from here on out how
many days um but at least it gets that
requirement out of the way this
committee does an official a vote on
each bill you know check that box and
then we can so ASAP I think so and I I
mean I think you get through all your
votes in probably an hour I mean I know
these are issues you're going to debate
much more but they could be debated as
part of a budget work session not necess
necessarily a work session on each
individual bill because the likelihood
of and I'm speaking way out of turn here
my sense is there's a maybe one or two
of these bills you'll pass the rest
you'll retain and debate them as part of
the budget yeah and honestly I just want
to get to the no more other no more
requirements other than General budget
work sessions because we have a lot of
work to do and all this stuff takes away
from that and could delay it so I'd like
this done as early as we can practically
not it with you know whever the chair
feels right but personally I'd like to
on go
ahead um so can you walk through again
I'm a little confused uh using the word
retain um and then having work sessions
um I think you know we've got a whole at
least a day's work here on anything
that's related to education so it seemed
to me that we'd be looking at a whole
day of discussion on these bills and
then making the motion of whether or not
you know making a motion on what to do
with them after we've had those work
sessions because I was hearing retain
and then work session so now I'm
confused about the sequence so let me
speak to that I think what he's saying
what representative PES is saying was we
would just
well speak for
myself we would take votes on retaining
them
as soon as possible and some of them
maybe we can actually get dispose of
beyond that but get get the voting out
of the way on that motion just as we
would have voted to retain just as I
would have voted to retain some of these
other bills earlier and we're not going
to talk about them until later next week
or or the following week so the same
situation handle the posting make the
make the motion to whatever you can make
a motion of your choice and we'll see
how it goes
but then have the actual but then have
the actual debate in terms of the let's
say let's just assume for a moment
they're retained then have the actual
debate over what to do about imp putting
them in the budget or not putting in the
budget further on so when you're saying
as soon as possible that's not a
euphemism for now oh well if if possible
yes but he has to notice that so the
soon as there'll probably be next
Tuesday or
Wednesday meeting notice requirements I
mean it's got to be done
properly representative Celly so so I'll
just sort of summarize what's in my mind
this is sort of a technical thing where
we're
retaining not killing it's still alive
but because of the technicalities of
trying to notice it in a time frame we
keep the bills and we can discuss them
so you are accurate but I just to be
clear about what's happened already
there's nothing that prevent somebody
from making an itl motion and trying to
kill it and we would take a vote on that
and but and then it would be dead or at
least would then go to the floor be dead
right or a motion to retain would be had
we' vote on that and then we wouldn't
have to deal with it right then in terms
of what we're going to do with it put in
the budget or let it ride until January
we then pick take it up further on next
week or early next the following week
everybody well Mr chair if I could just
um add the Democratic perspective to
this discussion is that it's clear to me
that you're willing to expedite the itl
bills that might be something that we
favor um to get those out of the way so
that you can continue deliberating over
the Appropriations for the bills that
you would like to retain so um I feel
like if we are going to notice this and
run to the finish line that we should
just acknowledge it that you know this
is a fast track for some bills and
others they'll be able to have longer
discussions I think you misunderstood me
I thought the it Tales would come from
I'm just basing this on
past over the my limited time with you
all and what we've done over the past
few weeks but they could go either way
anybody could make an ideal motion or
retain motion and we would get it we
would and since I seem to have sparked a
lot of this discussion I'll say that my
expectations that will retain all the
bills that we cannot decide in a brief
session will decide on those where we
have broad support in the committee that
we can dispose of them one way or the
other and then just get the notice
requirement of the out of the way so we
can finalize the work on the budget I
mean you know that's
all we certainly will need to have an
education work session maybe a full day
so all of these bills at least at least
four of them maybe five of them are ripe
for retain and all those topics will be
discussed and then for them to get into
the budget they'll require an amendment
that'll require a vote so um I think
just like representative Kelly it's
somewhat of a technicality here let's
get the requirement of the work session
on those bills take a vote on those
bills so we have a position on those
bills but the subject matter is probably
going to be deferred to a work session
and amendments as part of House Bill two
and House Bill one and two later on does
that make
sense yeah representative
Dy just so that I'm clear on this is it
are we retaining these because they just
passed down in the house and then we get
to talk about them now
no we can't do anything today no I don't
mean today but I'm I'm saying that's why
we're retaining them because they just
passed yeah yeah yeah these just passed
the other day okay so we have not yet
considered them so we've already we
haven't heard anything about them we
haven't okay I just want to make sure
that the audience and myself knows
exactly why we're doing this right so
we've already been through a number of
bills which we then going to be
executing tomorrow on full Finance these
are bills that just came to us that
eventually we have to deal with but more
importantly subsequent to that we then
have to really deal with them in terms
of how we put them into into the budget
or are we not putting okay I just wanted
you is everyone good with where we're at
with all of the requests that's and this
is this is what I have is everything at
this point um until we get to the next
house B two thing but I want to get you
out of here at noon today if I can as
well so moving to the next page yeah if
it's me you're rushing for I I I can you
know I can get past noon it be 12 30
maybe even 1 my next meeting is at two
up at the granite place okay uh the next
page you'll see is uh somewhat
underwhelming as far as detail this is
this is what you've these are the
decisions you've made to
date so just so so as as uh as you start
making um uh motions as you start making
changes adopting amendments I'll
populate this each day and keep a
running tab of you know all of your
changes to spending and Revenue by
Source well at least we didn't spend any
new money yet
true and then the next three pages I can
go through detail if you'd like but this
is just the an updated uh education
trust fund Surplus statement on line
seven um and then the only change to
this from what I gave you before is if
you look on line
28 charter school funding warrants and
fiscal 25 for division 2 the the
non-shaded column is $3 million I was
carrying a higher number the first
iteration the department said the
warrant might only be 3 million so I
updated that that helped the overall
picture by a few million dollars but
that's the only change from what you saw
before um as you can see going down to
line 53 over the
banum there 22.9 million in 26 and $79
million in 27 required from the general
fund to balance the education trust fund
with just what the governor put forward
that's where that's still effectively
point any questions on this one if not
fund so the highway fund has two two
differences here from the last version I
gave you one if you look on line uh
13 uh House Bill 649 which was passed by
the house I think last week relative to
vehicle inspections uh carries some
Revenue loss with it so I've reflected
that it's about 1 and a. half million in
the first year and almost $3 million in
year and then on line 19 the do
transfers uh this coming Friday a week
from today there is about a $4.3 million
winter maintenance request so I'm I've
included that in that number for
division two for fiscal 25 the
14801 that request number is in there so
that's assuming that fiscal iny that
that that transfer will be approved if
not we'll revisit this but so with those
two changes in there plus where we were
before going all the way down to the
bottom right corner you'll see we're
about $15 million hole in the highway
fund if I may on HB 649 right obviously
decreases some Revenue wouldn't there be
matching expenses did we ask the
Department of Transportation of what the
estimate is on the impact on the
department if that bill becomes law
obviously I'm not going to comment on
the chances of it making it through the
Senate and through the governor but if
it does do we have an estimate of the
reductions in expenditures from the do
because they would not have to
administer that it would be a department
of safety would administer that and
Beyond just the uh distribution of
stickers I'll have to see if they have
any other direct budget items relative
to U vehicle inspections and see if
there basically if we could check
because there should be a matching loss
of Revenue and loss of some expenditures
I find it actually surprising how every
time we add a new program they get new
expenses but when we remove remve them
the expenses rarely disappear not a
comment on a department in particular
just in general so I just want to make
sure that we are doing our due diligence
as time allows over those types of
questions yeah I can uh I can reach out
to the Department of Safety and see if
they can ID identify any direct or even
all
right and the last page here is just the
fishing game Surplus statement and this
has no changes from what I had provided
before so it still shows that they have
a a couple million dollar Surplus at the
end of the
bium
um what jumps out is if you look on page
or excuse me line 15 right across really
for all three years they're running out
of deficit every year so that the reason
this budget balance is is they start
this fiscal year with $13 million but
they end you know with just a couple so
you can see they're running at a a
deficit so this plan carried into the
next bium would have issues but we'll
hear way more on this Monday morning I
think
are you done are we done that's the end
of that document I don't know if there's
any other questions with with this as an
entire uh package or anything that
anyone has questions or wants to talk
about have we been through all of them
other than the hb2
index uh yeah
I don't think we're ever done but we may
be at the time where we can take a break
you know as in we may have done
everything for
today I I do want to walk or at least
make you aware of this document before
day so this is a
very uh informal um compilation I guess
I'll call it of all the house build two
changes that agencies have provided
again not including fishing game I
didn't have a chance to really process
their stuff from yesterday um and I've
ordered it Department of safeties first
then Department of Transportation then
Department of Education so when would
you have provided this electronically uh
I emailed this last night to everyone
and it is a posted on it's posted on the
well did it come with a fishing game
Bunch no it was an
email I don't know is
division two track it's not that group
right the division two I think it is in
the division two tracking there's four
attachments to that email it's this is
yes sure this this document is on on the
division 2 website
too about the oh okay yeah
okay I'm with you thank
you all right so again this is a pretty
informal just compilation just so you'd
have just one packet or one document of
the agency's house bill to uh draft
language they provided so these are
obviously not official OS amendments so
we can't act on these I'm providing
these to you just so you've got them and
if you do want me to draft an amendment
something you support something you want
to change let me know and I'll have
something drafted um I think everything
in here you heard from when the
departments were in they've done a good
job of there's some here that have like
a explanation or a reason for the change
or synopsis so hopefully that could
answer any questions if you you know
trying to remember why it was asked for
um but you can reach out to me if you
have questions on this stuff but
otherwise I'm going to just leave those
that ball in your court and if you want
any of these drafted to just let me know
and then I'll include them in the packet
for the committee to
consider so these will require
individual approvals or disapprovals by
the committee or modifications no
disapprovals really just if you do
nothing with it that's it but the these
are just to make you aware these were
asked for so I I had all the funding
requests on this document here these are
all the house bill two requests
effectively so um so if you want to
modify them or delete them then you need
to hear from you don't have to delete
them they're not these are not in House
Bill 2 oh this is like requested changes
to House Bill 2 oh oh oh I mean there
may be there may be one or two in here
this is the agency House Bill two
request most of it is new there may a
section that amends what's in here but
chances are what's in here is what they
requested we fixed the one safety one
that was a a mess up the rest of these I
believe are all new to House Bill too so
if we do nothing nothing happen they
they all die correct okay so we do need
to do something if we want them right
and that's what I'm saying if you do
support these requests from the agencies
okay and just a reminder we still have
this and regarding the fishing gam have
is most of what is most of the said what
you sent us or is there even more that
they have not yet sent us I've sent you
everything they they've sent and I'm
going to ask them to walk us through all
so I would ask all of you what what do
you want to do with our
time need to read them
yeah well do you want to do you want to
take some time and read them or do you
just want I mean this morning or you
want to not be you know call it a day
and what what we've got in another I it
would even take me it take I know it
would take me a while to even figure out
what I would need to read for today than
to just go home and read them all okay
that's fine I I just want to give you
all whatever you want to do You're great
and part of my part of the design for
why I wanted to get all this is so
hopefully you'd have the weekend to to
Really digest it all and and maybe come
up with a direction that either
individually or as a whoever you know to
how you want to proceed with some of
these things yeah just a quick question
you said that you just got the fishion
game last night and you didn't have time
to process them are you planning to
process some of them this afternoon and
send them to us for our review basically
asking if there will be an update to
this you know before the weekend or
we're just going to do that on Monday
after we talk to fishi and game I'm fine
either way just want to know what your
plans are I don't plan on updating this
one again uh and all of what I received
you've received so um we're good and
their requests are in there so those
documents essentially would act as if if
I had had them a little sooner I would
have tried to so there is no need to add
them here because we already have here
and then we already have the separate
Fish and Game email which for
Preparation purposes I will treat those
requests as being part of this yep okay
and I think that's fair and then same
same direction I would give you for the
fishing game either collectively as a
committee when we're discussing it
Monday or individually if you want to
support any of what they've brought
forward just let me know and I can have
some drafted we do I just didn't know if
there was more magic you were doing
before you put them in the packet and
I'm good no I mean I may if they got I
think they had other funding requests
besides just the general fund support so
I may add that to to this document here
kind of I may add those to there once I
understand what they're trying to do a
little bit um may be for Monday morning
maybe for Tuesday I'll I'll see I'd like
to do it for Monday but I'd also like to
hear from them too to be clear on what
they're looking to
do so I guess the other thing that while
we're here I would ask is is there any
other
agencies that you would like me to try
to get them to come in on a specific day
for a specific time to to talk answer
questions work through um just with busy
schedules of of the agency folk I'd like
I'd like to grab them sooner than later
if you know there's people you want to
talk
to uh sort of maybe moot at this point
um but I we I guess doe was expecting
some people from special ed to come in
and talk about I think more boots on the
ground experiences with special Leed so
I don't know if that was we could carve
out a little bit of an education day for
that I mean it's going to be a pretty
full day or day and a half or two um but
I did know there were people who were
concerned that special ed was not here
when we had the
hearing and when you say special ed they
special ed folks or no she was talking
about having um a coordinator or a
supervisor super someone who has worked
with the special ed and I think there
were some questions around what does it
really look like for a school district
to have a special ed student you know
how is that what you know what is that
year like when the student comes in um
I'm not necessarily making the
suggestion but putting out there that I
know that there was some concern about
having a little bit more understanding
of what's involved for a school district
Leed so we're going to schedule those
six bills for a work session and one of
those is the special education Aid Bill
the formal cat Aid bill um if it if it's
up to the committee to the chair that
those are of course are not public
hearings so it's really who would you
like to invite up I know we talked
earlier about quickly disposing them and
retaining them for a future work session
you could use that day to hear from a
non-state agency if you wanted to I
could invite someone to come talk about
from the local perspective on special ed
do you know who you want to have as it
oh I guess we could all ask around but
um I think it might be an important like
useful perspective to just understand
like how that can affect their
budget I'm not averse to it what true
costs are I think Caitlyn had some
people in mind so you could you know and
that's what I just want to understand
the intention of that work session day
because I I think when when the FAA Bill
an adequacy Bill a sped Bill are put in
the calendar you're going to get some
folks that are going to come through and
it's that then you know if the plan is
to abbreviate those discussions on the
bill retain it and then have a bigger
disc discussion another day you can
decide who you want to hear from on
which day or just let me know what to do
and then I can coordinate it so I just
want to be careful um I know I wasn't
here on Friday but I don't want a whole
group of people if there's a person that
you think would be appropriate and you
could do you want Mickey to talk to
somebody in
doe just ultimately a work session is up
to the committee and you can call in who
you want to speak so um
yeah yeah there's no requirement that
you allow everyone who comes out to
testify no no I I do understand that I
just want to be clear that that's the
intent and then the question is who's
going to pick the person and and I think
I can work with Caitlyn and if she has a
local administrator a special ed
administrator that she thinks could be
helpful to just share from how the local
the districts are doing Special Ed costs
um so if it's just a presentation and a
Q&A on our part if we could have that
person on the same like Tuesday whenever
you're doing this early retain thing
that probably be the time to do it so we
could when we get to the big day we
don't we're not bringing people in when
we're have enough time to discuss stuff
does that work okay I'll reach out to
the department and try to once I get a
date that in time we're going to have
this I'll reach out to the department
okay so are you all set in terms of I
think I've gone through everything for
today um just kind of wanted to lay all
that out there for you guys and kind of
talk about the process for the next
couple weeks it's going to go very quick
and we're going to have long days and um
again I I I know I sound like a broken
record but if you have Amendment ideas
even if it's a house bill one change get
them to me as soon as possible uh OS
will be inundated with all three
divisions plus all the other committees
and the Full House the full Senate doing
Amendment so we have a a time we want to
get everything done by so I don't want
to dump a bunch of stuff on them and say
we need all this by tomorrow you know
it's just I want want to be realistic
for them too so do you all have any
questions for me or for the committee
have I left anything you're good okay
all right I don't want
to leave any other questions before the
weekend I want you all to be psyched for
the weekend we psyched was the sped
administrator the only other because
we've got fishing game Monday I'll
invite the sped administrator do you
want to play it by year as we go through
or do you want to designate days at this
point like that's going to be your
education day or are you not prepared
not ready to do that yet I'm find
designated day if you all pick a day we
have and that can be something people
think about over the weekend and we
decide Monday as well you know they only
go ahead no go
ahead I my only concern um that's kind
of lingering from other things we've
talked about today is the 911 search
charge and safety
um and the the intention to put the
radio communications
in so and I assume you want to split
those out we actually talked about m I
talked about this um do you want him to
prepare an amendment to do that um well
I think there might be some intelligence
gathering worth um considering still
before uh we get to that phase I think
um it would be nice to hear from someone
other than the commissioner about what
the program the 911 search charge fund
does uh yeah I'm happy to to do some
work on that
um um my concern is that I think we're
getting one perspective when I think
that there might be other perspectives
and um it is a policy change not an
appropriation change and I think that it
might be worth hearing the other it's
both though right um potentially well I
mean potentially yes right so if you're
adding radio communications to the
911 searge fund then that means
something that would that is currently
being funded or in the past was being
funded without the radio communications
obviously something's not getting fully
funded anymore um because there's like a
new expense so um just so I'm clear so
if if I think if we follow through with
what you're what you're propos and I'm
not averse to it you would take
something out of that fund that's
currently being paid for that you don't
believe should be there so that would be
an expense somewhere else presumably for
safety yeah potentially right but of
course that's up to the you know the
committee's wisdom but no no of course I
just think it's worth having a fuller
discussion about that policy change 100%
agree is as long as you can come up with
concern and uh in one of the many emails
I've sent the department of safety did
provide some follow-up information and
there was a memo relative to that
discussion that may or may not help the
discussion just wanted to remind
everyone of that have you already sent
that to all of us that's sent and and
it's posted online too if anyone needs
to refer to that one so regarding safety
specifically the fee increases do you
think we certainly we got a a nice
document do you think we need to hear
from them because that would be the
other one I would it may not hurt to
have them in to uh discuss that as well
as anything else and just if you have
questions they're here and we could we
could designate a couple hour window
just to have them be available so so
that's one I would that's what I would
choose that the turnpike seems like it's
pretty like we really don't need to do
anything with it okay
yeah and are there any other there's
police standards but they seem to be
okay what are other the little ones are
there uh I mean Lottery depending on
what you end up doing with VTS could you
know you may want to hear from them
again they they also will will have some
uh position requests associated with
that which they put in their fiscal
notes relative to that those positions
were not included in the governor's
budget but you know they had I think
three positions relative to admin in a
compliance relative to if they took that
on so I do have that detail um that
would be part of a BLT amendment I think
so we probably should plan on them too
at some point but the amendment as I
understand that that the yeah the
amendment is being drafted so hopefully
we'll have that maybe certainly after
the
weekend and then once we have that we
could talk to Lottery about it yep yep
um and then I don't know if you need to
hear anything more from University or
Community College or if you're set with
what they provided that probably depends
on where we get to with everything
leading up to that
point because they have a
big budget um so maybe um but other than
that is education is the big one just to
you know and that's the one I'd like to
sort of hit as as early as possible just
because it's a lot to get through and it
has a big impact in terms of char school
funding EFA funding all those funding
pieces of that adequacy part um so I
think that's the the most important when
to hit early on you're saying of
assigning days for that can we do that
before the noticing or I I wasn't sure
how that was going to work I'm fine with
assigning days if we can I just wasn't
sure that we I think the assigning days
would be for our internal benefit to
know what your plan is for that day I'm
I'm going to post everything in the
calendar as budget work session to keep
it flexible so you're not bound to that
one issue on that day um but I'm I'm
just thinking for your preparedness as
well as if we do need an agency to come
in to be like hey you know we're doing
education all day that day so safety
don't bother coming in so all we have is
Wednesday and Friday I mean assuming you
can notice things so we we have two no I
know we have Monday and Tuesday but my
point is Monday is uh just in the
morning for a couple hours that's
fishing game Y and hopefully we can get
through fishing game and maybe something
else and then Tuesdays as soon as you
can notice you're not even sure you can
notice for Tuesday but let's let's hope
you can so I'm noticed for a budget I
know that but in terms of the the the
bills yep but even if we don't get to
those until Wednesday you'd still have
all day Tuesday to do anything too okay
so yeah you want to start an
education seems like education is going
to be the heaviest lift and um I think
it's important to spend the given the
limited time that we give education all
the time that we need to give it so fair
enough so but we can't do the retaining
at that point what so how does that all
work
yeah educ nice to actually get something
done as opposed to just talk about it
for eight hours yeah
um that's I was hoping we do Wednesday
yeah maybe Wednesday is is the safer day
then yeah if if we can
get things noticed for Tuesday or even
Wednesday yeah let let's see what we can
just get those Bill work session out of
the way first and then maybe because
that's like the I'm hoping we can do it
by Tuesday I don't know what the
requirement is I haven't heard back from
Janet yet okay um but if we can notice
that today maybe that's plenty of time
to do that Tuesday morning and then
you have a little bit more RS on pap and
if we plan on that notice required work
session to be brief I mean we can use
most of that day for a general budget
work session right so I would I would
budget that notice required work session
to be brief so that we can budget a
regular budget session on whatever
topics for the rest of that day right I
don't want to waste time too much time
with that my one hesitation of doing
education Too Soon Is I'm expecting
amendments and I don't have any yet so I
don't know what we would be doing
Tuesday um I'm I'm I'm envisioning maybe
your first so maybe start with safy yeah
you could get maybe safety and or even
you know roll through the other sections
a house bill too that maybe you're not
going to change but at least like get to
a point where you can vote on them to
accept them as is
um that sort of thing is there a reason
yeah the only reason why would not be we
yes
and welcome to finance yeah and there
there is a concern we're just keeping an
eye on the 26th is the drop dead date I
gave you that Wednesday is that could
also be a potential session day we're
hearing now so you may lose a day on the
back end of this I
it's really not not great to go past
that so yeah for now we are not going to
plan on Saturday or weekend work but uh
yeah it is a technical possibility so
plans so I guess safety be the one that
um be good to get in there especially
because they're they actually have
impact on general fund stuff as well
some impact anyway I'll try I think
that's a good idea especially the the
fee discussion because that's going to
be a big part of your balancing here
right uh see if I can first I want to
see if I can get the work sessions on
the bills scheduled that morning and
then maybe safety in the afternoon it
would probably be a productive day yeah
sorry that's Tuesday t uh Tuesday okay
so I'll do my best to find someone for
Tuesday afternoon if you can that'd be
great and I I'll I'll try to email
everyone by the end of today just so you
know if I may ask then what are we
planning to do on Monday just fishing
game because it looks like we may maybe
have a bit more time if we can find
something productive to do a couple
hours in the morning oh right sorry I
for got we have the full finance
committee session Mr landrier mention
and if if over the weekend you as a
committee have stuff you'd like to
discuss to help your planning we can
always like I said recess and come back
in here after the full committee work
that's that's an option too
so it
depends 25 people it's you know how
talking goes no I
[Laughter]
don't oh
no more no more comments
um
so good for today and hope for the best
next
week what's going on today well what do
you want to talk about that's what's
going on today nothing else we can
do got any ideas put them
forth I don't know the routine yet well
the the routine is you know what are you
we seem to be waiting on either
amendments or more information on most
topics that we could do if what the
chairman is saying is if you're aware of
a topic where we got all the information
and we can decide go ahead but we don't
see one I mean that's the mar have to be
noticed that's that's a
billed those bills are killing
us well what what darn committee put
hopefully that's the end of the bills
coming before crossover here we'll get
more obviously Senate bills later but
bills yeah go ahead is there ever a time
that these bills are passed by the house
I know this is a silly question and
we're planning for all of these
expenditures and then they get to the
Senate and they kill
them so yes so that do we have an idea
of which ones they're going to kill well
no but hang on so
that's the reason for
hb2 they can't kill bills that we put
into hb2 so all these bills that we've
retained the two choices we'll have are
let them go until January and be
considered or more likely put them into
hb2 hb2 is the last bill the house will
pass and pass to the Senate now the
Senate can mess around with it again but
it's messing around with the whole hb2
point
right okay does that make sense yes
okay well that's why hb2 becomes
this
monstrosity well so
[Laughter]
far all righty so without any further
comments at
11:48 I think it is I will
48 okay I will um declare the finance
[Music]